thanks for joining us America April is
in El Paso Texas hi April how are you hi
I'm - how are you better than I deserve
what's up well I had a question
my husband is military and was stationed
at Fort Bliss and well baby slept -
actually taking your class for the
second time he just come back from
deployment so we're getting back on the
paid for finances together tell him
thank you for his service oh well thank
you
and our had a question about vacations
and our vacation is normally spent going
home to see family and we stay with
family when we go home for expenses are
generally just getting there what are
your thoughts on that well I mean the
idea is very simple the more you spend
on other things the longer you're in
debt when you're working your baby step
to debt snowball right and so I mean if
you go on a $10,000 cruise it's going to
take you a long time to get out of debt
that's not what you're suggesting and so
the only thing you've just got to
measure it against is you've got
competing goals goal number one is I
want to get out of debt goal number two
is I want to go see family on vacation
these two goals are competing but you
know I'm the way I'm looking at it is
you know you make X you know what do you
guys make a year what's your household
income about 27 a year plus housing
allowance and what are you spending on
this vacation just the flat tickets home
and then of course eating that will eat
at my parents and what was just the
flight tickets home cost oh I'm sorry
and they're going to pay for half so we
have to pay for 616 okay okay $600 and
how much debt do you have we still have
about thirty thousand in debt and what
is that alone just did it one and that
and you make twenty seven thousand
dollars a year in the military yes okay
I just started a career but it's
commission based right now so I'm not
break
anything yet for the childcare okay um
well I mean you guys can do whatever you
want to do you got a lot of debt and you
don't have a ton of income but and and
yet it's it's I got to tell you it's
almost impossible for me to sit here as
much love as I have for military folks
we work with them all over the world and
and just appreciate you know the
sacrifices and a guy comes home off of
deployment once to go see his family and
a couple airline tickets I you know it's
hard for me to say that's not a good
idea of course it's a good idea you know
for you to go see your family but I just
want you guys to continually way out on
other decisions and this one you know
that you know we it doesn't change the
$30,000 much when you say 600 bucks
right right and so you're not using like
you're spending $6,000 or something like
that but you do have a lot of debt so
you just gotta have to say no to a lot
of stuff and if you're gonna say yes to
one thing and this is the one thing
that's fine but everything else is gonna
be no you know what I'm saying
I do because we say yes to six of these
ideas you're never getting out of that
rock you got you because you can find
six other things that are really
important things and good things and so
you got to just decide where we're going
to draw the line generally speaking I'm
just going to go no vacations at all
while you're in baby step two you're
getting out of debt shut up quit your
whining but you know your husband has
just come home from deployment and he's
serving in the sandbox you know and and
you guys don't make a ton of money you
got a big pile of debt it's going to be
a while and so if you want to kind of
cheat through this one that's fine but
you need to kind of know that the idea
is we're going to focus on everything
else on this one deal okay does that
make sense to you it does and we've
really been busting it we've been on it
for about two years and we've paid off
about thirteen thousand thirteen twelve
and thirteen very good you're making
progress what Ryan you are what that
you're doing that on 27,000 with two
kids you're doing good okay you are
you're making good progress the math on
that's pretty
Esav I mean you're not a slouch so I'm
not picking on you I just want you to
hear that because I don't want any the 8
million people listening to the show to
go okay I can go on vacation while I'm
in baby step 2
let me just tell you the answer that
usually is no right
why hey thanks for the call wanna know
thank you appreciate again your service
you